and out of the other big story this
morning Senate Republicans have named
the prosecutor who will question Supreme
Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh and
Christine Blasi Ford at a public hearing
tomorrow the Judiciary Committee
describes Rachel Mitchell as a career
prosecutor with decades of experiencing
experience prosecuting sex crimes the
committee plans to vote on Cavanaugh's
nomination Friday after it hears
testimony from Kavanaugh and the woman
who says he attacked her in high school
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with the
latest Nancy good morning good morning
and Mitchell came recommended by Arizona
Senator John Kyle Arizona Republicans
describe her to me as a longtime victims
advocate and very even keel Republicans
will defer to her at the hearing
tomorrow while Democrats ask their own
questions and Cavanaugh's future on the
Supreme Court could hinge on what
happens the confirmation hearing and my
judgment was an intergalactic freak show
even senators are stunned at how chaotic
this confirmation fight has become with
lawmakers trailed by protestors and
reporters wherever they go especially if
they're still undecided
nothing's changes I've gone to the
bathroom tomorrow's hearing with
Professor christine Blasi Ford and judge
Brett Kavanaugh will be high stakes and
highly unusual we have hired a female
assistant the 11 Republican men on the
Senate Judiciary Committee have tapped a
woman Arizona prosecutor Rachel Mitchell
to ask questions for them Democrats
called the move Patti's progressive and
continued to push for an FBI background
investigation for the first time a
Senate Republican Alaska's Lisa
Murkowski agreed with them an
investigation would certainly certainly
clear up some of the questions but other
Republicans are openly skeptical of
Blasi Ford's story that Cavanaugh held
her down and groped her at a high school
party what about the fact that it's an
accusation that is unknown in terms of
location or time the president slammed
Cavanaugh's
accuser Deborah Ramirez who says
Kavanaugh exposed himself to her at a
Yale University party she said she was
totally Lisa Calderon is close friends
with Ramirez in Colorado she could have
left out the part of drinking to make
herself seem a more sympathetic victim
but that tells me that she simply told
the truth Cavanaugh denies both Ford and
Ramirez as accusations Republicans say
they reached out to Ramirez his attorney
but they haven't been forthcoming with
the committee we reviewed an email chain
between the committee and Amy Ramirez as
lawyers and what we found was that
Republicans repeatedly refused to speak
to the attorneys until those attorneys
handed over all of their evidence in
writing Democrats say that kind of
demand is unprecedented
John Nancy thank you really interesting
about that email chain